une loi qui interroge celle sur le
renseignement voté le 24 juillet 2015
ans après l'attentât de charlie hebdo
cinq ans plus tard un audit était
attendue après une mission d'évaluation
présidé à part le député l air de
l'yonne guillaume larrivé deux constats
lusage de la reconnaissance biométrique
dans les affaires de renseignement doit
être repensée et le recours à
l'intelligence artificielle facilité et
pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec jean-michel miss député de loire
rapporteur de cette mission d'évaluation
de la loi
renseignements bonjour jean missionne
miss merci d'être avec nous ce matin sur
rtl fonce alors quel est votre retour
sur cette loi de renseignement est ce
que cette loi elle n'est pas déjà
obsolète comme le dénoncent certains de
vos confrères
non je crois qu'elle est pas obsolète
d'ailleurs la preuve qu'elle ne l'est
pas c'est qu'elle avait elle-même prévu
dans danser en sortie 26 une clause de
revoyure à 5 ans et donc qu'elle avait
parfaitement conscience que les enjeux
technologiques aujourd'hui faisait
qu'une loi ne pouvait pas être creed
dans le marbre pour une durée
indéterminée et donc par conséquent
cette mission d'évaluation avait
précisément pour pour mission de
contribuer à faire un bilan et de faire
des propositions dans le cadre des de ce
qu'est aujourd'hui le renseignement et
de ce que sont des outils qui sont
nécessaires à nos services alors cesser
l'usagé de la reconnaissance biométrique
notamment faciale qui a été pointée du
doigt dans ce dernier rapport c'est bien
ça
oui on a souhaité évoquer les enjeux du
moment donc évidemment la reconnaissance
biométrique figure aujourd'hui au centre
des enjeux en termes de renseignements
mais pas seulement puisque depuis 2010
le droit français inscrit déjà la
biométrie dans dans ses travaux à
travers le fichier des antécédents
judiciaires et donc par conséquent il
n'y avait pas de table ou dans la
manière d'aborder le sujet puisque c'est
un sujet qui est déjà traités sur plan
judiciaire sont leurs administratif
également pour rechercher un symptôme de
personnes lorsqu'ils prétendent à à des
fonctions sensibles et par conséquent il
était normal qu'on se pose la question
de l' usage de la reconnaissance
biométrique et de l'intérêt que ça peut
avoir la terre opérationnelle bien
évidemment l'intérêt pour la rechercher
et donc l'intérêt pour la protection de
nos concitoyens
est ce que vous pensez certains
pourraient déjà dénoncé une atteinte aux
libertés publiques notamment avec cette
reconnaissance biométrique cette
reconnaissance faciale
oui bien sûr je l'entends totalement
d'ailleurs c'est un peu de couple
naturel lorsqu'on vous prend des mesures
qui sont attentatoires ou qu'ils peuvent
paraître attentatoire aux libertés
publiques il est absolument normal qu'en
face nous apportions des garanties qui
permettent de corriger les atteintes qui
pourrait être celle d'un tel dispositif
qui effectivement peut être intrusif par
sa nature par l'absence de contact et
par le fait que les personnes qui
pourraient y être soumis ne sont pas
forcément informés de busage de cette
technologie c'est ce qu'on essaie de
rendre dans deux rapports avoir un
regard équilibré à la fois
opérationnelle est évidemment soucieux
d'assurer les garanties nécessaires et
on reprend d'ailleurs dans ce rapport
d'une manière assez large à satan de
préconisations ou de recommandations et
d'inquiétude
porté par la commission nationale
informatique et libertés d'ailleurs en
fin 2019 et je crois qu'on est de ce
point de vue là à c'est assez carrée sur
sur la manière de renforcer à la fois la
protection et la protection dans les
deux sens celle du citoyen et puis
évidemment la protection générale des
citoyens dans le cadre des missions
portées par cette foi de renseignements
vous parlez de garantie instant qu'elle
serait justement les garanties que vous
apportez à ce projet
les premières garantie c'est d'abord que
cette loi respecte justement les
finalités pour qu elle l a été fait et
donc de ce point de vue là la biométrie
ayant été aujourd'hui assez clairement
défini par la cnil notamment pas
seulement l'idée effectivement de garder
un usage proportionné de ces
technologies lorsqu'elles sont
réellement indispensable évidemment de
ne pas recourir dans l'espace public
d'une manière totalement indifférenciée
à des technologies qui sont très
intrusive et donc évidemment la
réflexion sans tabou que je le rappelais
est porté sur cette technologie même si
le rapport ne formellement ne requiert
pas et ne demandent pas évidemment
l'élargissement cette technologie
particulière on considère que la
réflexion doit encore mûrir parce qu' un
certain nombre de biais sont connus
aujourd'hui par rapport à mozilla qui
sont amenés à mettre en oeuvre ces
techniques de reconnaissance et par
conséquent les états n'est pas encore
totalement mature pour un déploiement de
cette technologie les services que nous
avons d'ailleurs auditionné dans la
mission ne disent pas autre chose
puisque la plupart des services estime
le besoin de reconnaissance biométrique
à horizon 5 ans voire 10 ans donc ce
rapport finalement soulève le problème
et soulève la nécessité de réfléchir
encore plus à fond sur ce sujet là mais
ne préconise pas un usage immédiat et
nous allons plus loin nous nous
considérons même que si le la biométrie
devait être envisagée devrait l'être au
titre d'une technique en soi et donc
effectivement faire l'objet d'une
réécriture législatives est donc un
contrôle évidemment du parlement merci
beaucoup jean michel huys d'avoir été
avec nous à ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes député de la
loire et rapporteur de la mission
d'évaluation de
la loi sur le renseignement merci
beaucoup